[Music]
it's it's a it's a jump bone like a
trombone but no that was a very funny
sort of God I am bunchy here to this
[ __ ] show man I don't want to do that
[ __ ] anymore you guys heard it you just
heard it I'm never gonna be back to you
again you got one more chance all right
he was big nice nice you got one more
chance fill your fans don't want to see
me anyways yeah they do this week we've
got stolen ambulance Fried Chicken bath
and Varro Honda take it away Tiffany
take it away
bye-bye viral Honda's is that a Honda
with an ST that took an ambulance for a
door ride but he did not realize that
there was still a paramedic and a
patient in the back there's so many
things that like had to go wrong for
that to happen I agree and I actually
wanted to find out more about this I'm
like okay who's this guy how do you even
get there what happened I can't answer
any of those I just know that there was
a man that's stole a New Zealand is you
don't need to answer I'll show you guys
the video I already know what it's a
meth
maybe dude meth heads have the craziest
[ __ ] and the crazy is pets why they're
the best brain stores I don't know how
they obtain these things but I've seen
memes or not even names but they're like
pets raccoons is pen yeah icon at leash
and I'm like
like how do you get that yeah I should
do that
snow white they're like snowy they're
able to gather the animals to come they
look like a crack it Sleeping Beauty
sorry Stephen Beauty was the one that
had like all the merriment Cinderella I
thought snow I had animals to do Snow
White Cinderella oh yeah this is white
it is snow oh wait no I was think
cocaine so I don't know my drugs you
don't know anything about drugs fill
that you guys do we yeah what is snow
why is it Snow White in the seventh
doors yes I saw a porno that was in the
70s no why in the seven snorts what I
think I'm a rapport no because you're
bringing up you bring that point oh
really
it's pretty dope which part off there's
a snow white poor node and it's like
European mate he said it before
okay few times there's Seven Dwarves
gangbangs just the white tell me more
yeah the production value believe it was
it was and there's a funny thing is that
it was actually a Disney movie - yeah
it's charming and then the Wicked Witch
having less fun action with their
servants I think you're just making this
up in your head now no I'll link it to
you all right I gotta watch that later
I'm gonna show you a clip of this dude
getting pulled over or finally getting
stopped that's so why - ambulance ended
up calling 9-1-1 she was in the back she
was like my ambulance just got stolen
I'm in the back with the patient so yeah
oh did you car guys I hope the patient
did it die yeah I wanted to find out
more about the patient but I did can you
imagine you're like dying and then
someone steals your [ __ ] humble ass
you know what I was thinking - I'm like
isn't there always a driver and then
like at least one or two paramedics in
the back what if they got the bunga's
and they had poopoo
I don't know what hopper
oh look at driving skills police driving
skills are so dope Paula Mauer
beat the crap out of he's brave all that
must hurt so bad
is the presto movie
ah good job guys no yeah get that
[ __ ] man I think if I was a cop and I
was taking somebody down I'd be highly
offended that three of my other homies
came in and pulled him down - I got this
dude what the [ __ ] man [ __ ] I'm honestly
I'm against police brutality but I'm
also a fan of it at the same time if you
know what I mean how are you so I don't
think it's right that police use
excessive force on innocent people that
is not correct
but seeing sheer violent movement like
seeing a cheetah take down a gazelle
that's art it's like football yes but in
real life yeah I only like police
brutality when it's well-deserved like
all the evidence
I don't like innocent police but but I
like let's say that guy yeah literally
finger two kids [ __ ] yep that
[ __ ] should be beaten
jeffrey Brown
do you like police brutality he looks
like he was drunk he is look he's about
to cry I know he looks like he's a rug
rat rug rat rugs rat hump
rugs are at I heard of that before
kidnapping abduction grand theft auto
and failure to comply echo Somalia robot
yeah yeah he didn't match the
description when I was thinking uh meth
head I was think my person that's what I
thought I thought oh uh we don't know
it's a method we just you just me that
uh like a redneck guy with the baseball
helmet with two beer cans
what are you be at home watching the
game reserve no but that just went crazy
you know be fun my wife [ __ ] still in
the fan blades
how did like why was the ambulance left
unattended or was it hijacked or what a
charger
Oh thinking really - I'm like I want to
know these things like and you know what
he's a little too old to be like that I
would I would picture like a teen or
someone that [ __ ] around and like you
know I want to play GTA yeah he looks
like he should be long in Captain
Phillips Anisha so weird how like I'm so
conditioned to think about ethnicities
when it comes to certain crimes yeah
yeah I mean like if there's something
really crazy like that I think a white
person yeah petty crime I think black
people if it's like if it's a mass
shooting why people yeah well if like
somebody's like face-fucking like a dead
corpse I think a Japanese person it's
it's weird like I'm so conditioned was
that what was necrophilia Japanese
really you know massive drug dealing
Mexican saw Chinese fraud Chinese weird
that where that white collar's human
smuggling like Vietnamese or Southeast
Asian excessive beating of your children
asian asian what else is there leaving
your kid outside people of the brown
complexion all of us yeah carjacking
black people what else is there
I put Asian people in carjacking too
though yeah depends on how what type of
Asian embezzlement and fraud white
people you know we should break the
crime stereotypes guys I know should
start doing things no all right we
should learn from that though so there's
equality in crime why can't there be
equality justice equality in crime just
ever like that it's all different it's
different but there everyone's doing the
same shady [ __ ] some form or some way
you know yeah but they're even though
even the crimes are stereotypical the
punishments aren't the same though
that's the best line TV has molded my
mind that's what happened it's the news
fault
judge Judy's fault glad that this didn't
turn into a shooting right that could
heat it could've easily gone that way
yeah that's true they treated him with
respect that's right it was it was a it
was a very nice tackle yeah and that's
all it needed to be
they took him down like a white person
that's all
that was really nice I saw that well I
suppose one of you like a like a white
guy like pointing a gun at a confident
guys just like stop stop just him around
the white guy was pointing the gun at
the cop and the guys just like just
stopped me and then the white guy starts
running and then dude couple rows
running running after him and even got
into the cop car for a little bit Imran
we smoked a little bit yeah they [ __ ]
a [ __ ] was from a small town and they
probably knew each other Cletus this is
not a can Cletus drop the gun for our
next story
KFC in Japan they teamed up with a
novelty real retailer called Village
Vanguard and so they created a Fried
Chicken bath bomb my dream come true.you
jeana's gonna be all over this actually
tweeted out youtube we like so your bath
dick smells like fried chicken yes and
then you smell like fried chicken when
you come out of the bed looks like it's
frying dude fried chicken is so cool
turns the water orange it looks oh you
know what that looks like you know when
you get chicken and you you soak it in
water
oh yeah blood water right oh yeah I'm
good with this that [ __ ] smells so good
though you can smell it already huh I
can smell it too but I can't see them it
was if it was Popeyes you see this man
knows what's up I hate KFC KFC is a
different type of restaurant in Japan it
is a fancy go out to eat date spot it
they changed man
yeah because back in 2004 or something I
would agree with you about KFC in Japan
but when we recently went I had this
memory of KFC being so [ __ ] good and
I ate it at that [ __ ] and I said I
wanted to throw the chicken bone at them
and so how is this [ __ ] case maybe
your standards have gotten higher since
2004 Spears you're like a foodie
you know oh you know that is true though
now you're like I've had such good fried
chicken because I remember a baby like
those extra large hot pop is being
really bombed but recently it was pretty
[ __ ] no Bagel Bites is my thing
I love bigger bites in the freezer
section is delicious you know you know I
think we like I think I liked it because
my mom never let me have it
so when I did get it it was it was like
some kind of gourmet delicacy yeah I
never did we a song for her it's always
what you don't have look at this is your
clearly I had so many hot pockets I just
want my mom to cook for me everybody
only cooks are stupid we will never know
joy without pain because I'm thinking
like as a kid my mom was like making
fresh food you see the commercials on TV
as a kid
and you're like oh it's all the kids are
eating it and then you have to eat your
little Chuck chain your little like
noodles and your rice is so mad because
I remember with those hot pocket
commercial yeah I wanted to be like that
but kids actually want saltier stuff
like the taste buds hmm that's true this
they want sugary and salty there's more
you're [ __ ] I never grew out of this
sugary yeah so these bath bombs will be
only available to 100 lucky Twitter
followers so they're raffling it off oh
they're just making a hundred yeah I
don't like smelling like fried chicken
though like I do go to Korean barbecue
you come out smelling Korean barbecue
yeah I want smoked food I like to smell
a few bottles that's why the Korean
barbecues wants to have the bench that
has the like you can put your jacket
inside oh yeah yeah
those are the nice spots I think it's
because you guys are thinking about old
fried chicken think about when you
freshly fried chicken and then the aroma
of that fills the room versus you got
the fried chicken you let that
[ __ ] sit for a couple of hours
and then you smell did that look at this
snobby fried cheese no that's what I was
thinking about thinking about the first
one I don't think anyone wants to smell
like grease do you want to smell like
popcorn no you're gonna agree with me I
want to smell like soap and Cologne
why do you want to smell like a
middle-eastern middle-aged man she wants
about like a hamburger patty
I would like to consume it's my popcorn
because it's kind of bare do you want to
smell the car exhaust
wait so you put here see you at the top
still no fried chicken well okay of the
fried chicken though what do you guys
drink that's what yeah I've been like
your church's louisia fried chicken
Popeyes what's weird what's Louisiana
Fried Chicken you never had it cuz you
never back to the ghetto so okay you
know how binamis people are nail salons
yeah Cambodian Chinese people owned
Louisiana style fried chicken and they
only exist in the ghetto so if it
doesn't have bulletproof glass it's not
a right chicken place hmm so that's my
top favorite or I have noticed that you
know you go to like those like holding
the walls like takeout Chinese place
that I like owned by Mexican you know
people like there we have the best fried
chicken no no a lot of times it sucks I
feel like I've seen like we're like The
Kooks actually go up off and open their
own yeah cuz they know that they because
they love that some people are thieves
you know why because people in a ghetto
love fried chicken and Chinese food yeah
and it's a great combination is I know
what you're talking about well hold on
it's like those places if you go to LA
yeah you'll see the sign it's split it
says Chinese food fried chicken and
doughnuts and then laundry yeah yeah
boom or like in between k-town it
downtown like this that there's this
restaurant it's like all like dragon
sombrero or some [ __ ] alright for our
last story there's this man who created
a really dope car commercial for his
girlfriend's used 1996 honey oh that is
awesome yeah how much is he selling it
for starting price
well now it's viral so yeah now it's
gone viral but the starting price was
$4.99 father bun what kind of Honda is
8600 corn ooh that's a good one that's a
classic
wait that's only worth $500 no dude it
might be a starting bid yeah but I hate
it Brady
1996 was over 20 years ago when I'm a
millionaire I'm gonna buy every single
[ __ ] Honda Acura Toyota that I
dreamed about in the 90s I'm gonna get a
Mitsubishi 3000gt the one that was the
defender style is legend of the clip we
gotta make you rich Joe I need to see
this and I'm gonna [ __ ] rice rocket
the [ __ ] out of them I could have an
import show just by myself
I'm already started I got the Honda no
one cares about that car oh come on now
I actually wanted the element for a
while like I got one
you see exactly he's a course warrior
it's a very practical car thank you it's
bright it's a good grip truck yes
that's he knows what's up come on and
you can like hose it down inside that's
a tissue box are wheel I'll tell you
this though now when I go to my local
like taco joints and like taqueria this
[ __ ] nobody looks at me I look like I'm
one of them because you can because
every time I'd ride the the Tesla there
you just get some weird looks it just
feels really yeah you're something you
can get that car because you already
have a Tesla I just wanted the elbow
so actually we are not this all right of
the chest flat base okay foundation I
haven't built that yet guys
[Music]
this dope you you're different he heard
a matter do things your way it's not his
real girlfriend so she's a hooker
you don't need that is so nostalgic that
car the [ __ ] iPod you don't care
about I told that cat out the window
though I'm allergic you don't do it for
appearance's Wow
that's dangerous this is this shot
really well that's they actually make
they shot like a Mercedes all night
they're shooting it just like a [ __ ]
car commercial use 1996 Honda used
[Music]
luxury is a state of mind that's that
commercial cost more than a damn car
that's for sure
when you sell your car no no that that
honestly that's the that's the benefit
of having a boyfriend that's in like
creative arts that makes me so mad
that's what that's what YouTube did to
like the world now I can all do that I
literally wrote that for my Honda
Element Oh and now I feel like you did I
feel like I'm sure you'd boy like if you
release a video like I was gonna do
something just like that but it was
making fun of the fact that because I
had a Tesla I'm so spoiled I don't know
how to use a car without its technology
but I was gonna do it like a
professional commercial no it's it just
it just killed my yeah I killed it this
guy here his name is Max he said that
they got the idea when they were driving
up th PCH is beautiful
yeah they decided to just get the drone
out and then a friend of his his help
shooting they're shooting a cannon no
it's the cannon yeah so they were just
like oh this would be funny if we did in
Toulouse don't they got it they got a
nice head over here with like their
probes they I mean they're obviously
they know what they're doing yeah blue
boxes in the back of the truck dude they
were like on their way to issues yeah
straight up the corn was probably like
their production like office like car or
something yeah yeah so they started the
bid on eBay for four hundred and ninety
nine dollars and then eat it got all the
way up to a hundred and fifty thousand
no yeah and actually surpassed that
amount and then eBay someone and eBay
was like wait there's no way in 96 Honda
is going for this much so they cancelled
it think what a rod what a [ __ ] hatin
ass [ __ ] yeah so then he started a
second auction but obviously it wasn't
as high it
eBay canceled the second auction as well
[ __ ] know we just have to wait and
see well you know what [ __ ] eBay I used
to sell airsoft guns on you [ __ ]
and you suspended my account
that's right [ __ ] I still remember this
was 2004 I was trying to be a
businessman and I [ __ ] called your
ass and guess what I got some fake-ass
American with an accent they're not even
American and [ __ ] and they couldn't even
help me out [ __ ] you eBay unless you
want to sponsor us I'll forgive you this
video is almost hitting 5 million views
do you think someone would have actually
paid it though like who wouldn't yeah do
you think they've been trolling it this
video has been viewed like all over the
world it's like hella more like what are
you gonna like after you get the car you
tell your friends hey this was the car
in that one borrow a video like David
house they just won in 96 oh my hey I'm
still gonna do my damn video I'm
piggybacking off this it's my future
dang dude you know when I saw this it
felt like deja vu I could have sworn we
talked about something like this a few
years ago but I don't know I don't
remember
I remember fans of JK find that video
yeah maybe go fans a JK save [ __ ] eBay
unless they want to sponsor you unless
unless they say so I'm not associated
with with them BB hi how's it going
how's it going
unless you say sorry you guys get such
amazing sponsorship I know what do you
guys got [ __ ] JCPenney AT&T well you
could you could afford that times two
you know how many you know how many
people had a Rob to get my [ __ ]
[Music]